CALUM BARNES: This
is IOT205, which
is about growing the
IoT with LPWAN and LoRa.
My name is Calum Barnes.
I'm a product manager
on Cloud IoT Core,
and I also focus on working
with low power networking
technologies for Google.
I have with me an awesome
team that I'll let
introduce themselves, as well.
VIVEK MOHAN: My
name is Vivek Mohan.
I'm the Director of Marketing
for a lot of products
at Semtech.
VICTOR HAMON: And
I'm Victor Hamon,
Product Manager at Objenious.
CALUM BARNES: All right.
Awesome.
Thanks, guys.
This is hopefully going to be
both exciting and educational
today to talk about LPWAN
technologies and LoRa.
Both Objenious and Semtech
are founders of LoRa Alliance
and Leaders in the Space.
We will have time for
questions at the end,
but given the format that we're
in here, if you have questions
throughout, I think it's
good to have a discussion.
We're each going to be
talking about different areas.
So feel free to put your hands
up or come up to the microphone
here.
The presenters have
told me they prefer
that so that they can actually
hear you on the recording.
But feel free to
ask questions or let
us know if there's things you
want us to clarify when it
comes IoT connectivity options.
So if you've been to
the other IoT sessions
at NEXT the previous two
days, you've probably
seen this slide a lot, but
we're connecting more things
to the internet
than ever before.
But actually, what
this session is about,
is about those things
that haven't been
connected to the internet yet.
For one reason or another,
they struggle with the existing
connectivity options.
And there's generally
a few reasons
that products or
companies struggle
when they're trying to connect
things to the internet.
And it comes down to
power, cost, and range,
or some combination
of the three.
So first of all, power--
there are a lot of devices
that don't have main power
or can't be
recharged frequently.
And that makes it
hard, in some cases,
to actually get the connectivity
to them that they need,
especially if they
need to broadcast
long ranges over wireless.
Next is cost-- and
this comes down
to module cost, as well
as recurring costs that it
takes to actually connect
devices to the internet.
And this is especially a problem
for devices or applications
where you need to connect
a huge number of devices
in order to get significant ROI
on whatever your use case is.
Even as module costs come
down and connectivity costs
come down, there
are still use cases
that need it to be cheaper,
need it to be smaller,
need it to be more
power efficient.
And, finally, range,
which generally comes into
account on
compounding these two.
So we have pretty good
low power options today.
We have pretty good
connectivity infrastructure
that you can connect
to for pretty cheap.
But if you need your devices to
connect over very long ranges,
or in lots of
situations, then this
can also be a big challenge.
So let's talk about
some of the use cases
that this is a challenge for.
One that I think is
very interesting,
and is applicable to LPWAN, is
metering and smart metering.
So this has been a problem
that smart cities and energy
companies have wanted to solve
for a long time, where instead
of sending somebody around to
each energy meter to read it,
they want it to be able
to report automatically
all the time.
But there are challenges here
because the energy company
typically doesn't control
the connectivity, which
is near the meter.
Generally, energy meters are in
weird locations in buildings.
And, honestly, it's pretty
cheap to send somebody
around and read each
meter individually.
So in order to get
good ROI, reading them
has to be radically cheaper.
Next is agriculture.
So, agriculture, whether
its livestock or farming,
has challenges in
connectivity because you
have big open spaces,
and in some cases,
you have lots of assets.
So you can't put a cell
phone on every single cow
that you have to
track its location.
And if you have
large open fields,
you might need lots of
environmental sensors
in areas where there isn't even
good cellular connectivity,
let alone mains power
to keep them going.
And, finally, one that Vic
is going to talk to you more
about later is asset tracking.
And I think this is a really
good example of why LPWAN
is going to help grow
the IoT because things
like asset tracking
and fleet management
are not new IoT use cases.
There's lots of companies
out there doing this today.
But given the cost
of connectivity,
whether it's keeping the
devices cellular connected
or having to recharge the
batteries all the time,
it's kept asset tracking only
to pretty high value assets.
So companies still have a
hard time tracking everything
through the entire supply chain.
So before we start talking
about new solutions
and how they can help
these industries,
let's look a little bit
about how things work today.
You have three major options
for connectivity with IoT today.
And I promise you probably
know about these if you're
here at this session
listening to this,
but it will be important
for framing things later.
You have personal area
networks, and these are things
like Bluetooth, SIG, Thread.
And they're great for
short range communication,
and they already are
quite power efficient.
There's lots of exciting things
happening in this space today.
Then you have local
area networks.
This is what a lot of IoT
devices choose to use,
things like Wi-Fi and ethernet.
We have great existing
infrastructure for it.
Almost everybody has
Wi-Fi in their house.
It works most of the
time, unless you're here
at a conference like
this, then maybe it works.
But even with advances
in costs, we still
have mediocre battery life on
Wi-Fi and ethernet devices.
And finally, you have
traditional cellular options,
which give great
range, great coverage,
and the networks are already
deployed in most places.
But both the cost
of the modules,
and the recurring costs of
paying for cellular data,
can be quite expensive,
especially if you're
trying to connect
millions of assets
for whatever your project is.
So now let's talk
about how LPWAN,
which is a technology that's
really a set of technologies,
which have really been driven
by the needs of IoT customers
and IoT use cases are
starting to change this.
So LPWAN technologies can give
you much better battery life
than cellular and Wi-Fi.
They can give you better range
than personal area networks
and can be cheaper than
traditional cellular,
but it does come at a cost of
much, much lower bandwidth.
But for IoT applications,
this is actually
generally not a problem.
Being able to sacrifice
bandwidth because you only
need to send a few bytes
of sensor data a day
actually makes a
lot of sense if you
can connect these
devices super cheaply,
have them run on a single
battery for years at a time,
while communicating to base
stations that are miles away.
So let's see how LPWAN stacks
up to our existing connectivity
options in the few
key areas that we
talked about causing problems
for IoT connectivity today.
So, in terms of
range and bandwidth,
you have personal area networks
that are sort of low on both,
and then you have
cellular networks
that give great bandwidth
and great range today.
LPWAN is somewhere down here
on the bottom, where you
have very, very low bandwidth.
In some cases,
only bytes per day.
But you actually have as good,
if not maybe a little bit
better, range with
some LPWAN technologies
than traditional cellular.
Now let's look at cost.
You have pretty much the
existing infrastructure
and the PAM technologies are
very, very low cost today,
both in terms of module
and overall pricing.
And then you have cellular,
which give great range.
But not only are
modules more expensive,
but you have to pay a cellular
provider every single month.
And even with new
IoT pricing plans,
it can be quite expensive
if you need to connect
large numbers of devices.
And this is where
LPWAN is really
going to help companies bring
down the cost because you have,
again, just as good
a range as cellular,
but in many cases,
much lower costs.
And that's driven by the
size of the payloads.
But it's also driven by the
fact that, if you want to,
you can deploy LPWAN
yourself and then you
don't have any network
provider that you're
paying every month, every year.
Now let's talk about power
usage or, ultimately, how long
you're going to get on battery.
And I think this is
where it really shines
through how great LPWAN is.
You have your traditional PAN
technologies-- like Bluetooth,
Threads, IGBT, the
[INAUDIBLE] technologies--
down here where we have
very, very low power
usage but very, very low range.
And then you have, in
the opposite corner,
traditional cellular.
LPWAN, we're hoping,
is going to change this
because we can get almost
as good battery life
as we do with the personal
area network technologies
and almost as long a range
as with traditional cellular.
So this set of technologies
is pretty exciting
going forward for helping
drive more adoption in IoT.
So let's talk about
some of the options.
And I'm going to let the other
guys get up here because they
are the experts.
But you have Sigfox,
which is a single vendor
but multi-national network,
where you can go to them
and buy one radio that will
work in multiple places.
You have LoRa, which is
driven by the LoRa Alliance
open network technology that
has network providers, which
support it in many places
in the world today.
And then you have NB-IoT,
which is a standard from 3GPP,
so the same standards group that
does the 3G and 4G standards.
And typically these
are networks that
are deployed by traditional
telecom companies.
Today we really want to
focus on talking about LoRa
and telling you more about that.
So without further ado,
I'll have Vivek come up
and talk to you about it.
VIVEK MOHAN: Thanks, Calum.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
VIVEK MOHAN: So we're going
to touch on LoRa technology.
And then Victor will
talk about how it's
used in an actual use case.
So as we start,
you know, Semtech--
for those of you who are not
familiar with the company--
we are a semiconductor company.
We've been around for 60 years
designing analog mixed signal
IC's.
And about five years ago,
we saw customers trying
to solve a problem, right?
There's many use cases
that you can see up here
in the smart city segment, in
supply chain and logistics,
in smart buildings, where you
have these sensors that don't
have access to line power.
They may be monitoring leaks
in a pipe in your basement,
they may be an elevator
shaft detecting vibration,
or it may be a water meter
or a gas meter that's
buried deep underground.
And these don't send a lot of
data to the network, right?
So they may send, a few
times a day, small payloads.
They need to have
really long range,
and existing technologies don't
offer the power consumption
and the cost benefits.
So if you look at
Wi-Fi or Bluetooth,
you really need to add
in a lot of repeaters.
Or you need a mesh
network like Zigbee, where
it adds cost of infrastructure.
So if you look at the Capex
and OPEX, it doesn't work.
So we brought a
lot of technology
to the market with the goal
of providing long range
connectivity at a
fraction of the cost
and fraction of power
consumption of existing
technologies.
So what is LoRa, right?
There's fundamentally two
ways people send data out
of these sensor networks.
You know, if you've attended
any of the IoT sessions
at this conference,
a lot of talk
is about edge computing
with the httpu announcement,
Cloud computing-- all
of this needs data.
But the problem that
enterprises and businesses
are trying to solve
is, how do you
extract data from these things
that could be located anywhere,
right?
That's a hard problem
to solve, and that's
where Semtech comes in.
So if you look at
the figure here,
you can see that you
can either optimize
for frequency, spectrum.
So if you're using licensed
spectrum, like NB-IoT or LTE,
traditionally the
entire network is
architected to be optimized
around spectrum efficiency,
right?
That's their main driver
because it's expensive.
With LoRa, it operates
an unlicensed spectrum.
And we use something called
spread spectrum, which
is beneficial because we
live in a very noisy RF
environment, right?
There's Wi-Fi,
there's Bluetooth,
there's all sorts of things
constantly transmitting
around us.
So you need to have
a technology that
can [INAUDIBLE] robust in
the presence of interferers.
And we'll spread spectrum,
which allows the receiver
to actually recover
the signal even if it's
below the noise level it's low
power and it's low complexity.
So if you're to scale LPWAN
and IoT to the millions
and billions that
analysts are predicting,
the cost has to be extremely
low at the sensor side, which
means we don't want to add a
lot of processing complexity
or processing capability
all the way of these sensors
for these types of applications.
So we focused on
building LoRa and LoRa
WAN on low power and
to keep the end nodes
and the hardware
costs really low.
It's bidirectional with
adaptive data rates.
So if you can think about
it-- if you have a gateway,
and you have a sensor that's
maybe closer to the gateway,
it doesn't need to blast out
its packet at full power, right?
You can back off the power.
And all of that is network
controlled with something
called adaptive data rate.
So you can trade
off of the data rate
for range and optimize power
consumption on the sensor side.
It's tolerant to moving objects.
So for asset management,
which, you know,
Victor show you an
example of how LoRa WAN is
used in asset tracking.
You can still use this.
I mentioned robust interference.
And one of the key features
related to asset management
is GPS-free geolocation.
So you can do this if you
have an application or a use
case that requires
anywhere from maybe 50
meters in a rural
environment to 150
meters in an urban environment.
We're not talking about
submeter accuracy, right?
But there's plenty
of applications.
You may need to do geofencing
or see if a car in your fleet
has left a certain
area, things like that.
So there's many use cases
where GPS, as we all know,
is extremely power hungry,
and it obviously adds
cost to the sensor as well.
So we figured out a way using
time difference of arrival
to know where the sensor is
without adding additional cost
on the sensor itself.
So it provides good location
for outdoor applications
without battery
impact, in the sense
that there is no GPS trying
to acquire satellites
in a position fixed constantly.
It's bidirectional,
so if you want
to do firmware
updates over the air.
Now, in these applications,
because the sensors
may be in places that are
very difficult to access,
but they still need to
last five 10, 15, even 20
years in some
cases in the field,
over-the-air updates
are important.
You can have acknowledgments
come back from the network
indicating that the
network's received a packet.
And also for key
exchange, right?
You can activate
sensors over the air,
so you need bi-directional
communication.
LoRa WAN is driven
by the LoRa Alliance.
It's an industrial lines
of over 500 companies,
and LoRa WAN is the
MAC Layer protocol.
And the aim of this is to
standardize and open-source
the MAC Layer protocol so
that you have interoperability
amongst all these sensors,
and we can kind of
define some standards around
it, which is a real way
to scale all of these networks.
It's got global
support, and it also
supports roaming
across networks.
And security is
really important.
You know, these end nodes,
they may have a secure element
in some cases to store the keys.
So security and provisioning
is also thought of all the way
from the sensor to the Cloud
and different layers in between.
So what does the architecture
look like, right?
You've got a bunch of
sensors transmitting data,
and most of these are
uplinked to the gateways.
The way this is architected--
it's a start apology.
And any gateway within
range of a sensor
will be able to receive
the packet, right?
So typically, in
an installation,
you have more than one
gateway that a sensor can hit.
So the sensors send
packets up to the gateway.
The gateways are pretty
simple packet forwarders.
There's not a huge amount of
processing complexity, again,
with the aim of offloading
all of that processing
to places where you have
the capability to do that
and the resources to do that.
So we want to keep the
cost of these gateways--
not only of the sensors, but
also the gateways-- really low,
right?
And then you've got the network
server and the application
server, which could
reside in the Cloud
or maybe on premise
in some applications
if you have other concerns.
So one thing that's
important to note
is, you know, Calum mentioned
Sigfox and NB-IoT and LoRa's
options, right?
And when we think about
wide area networks,
we typically think of the
mobile network operators.
In the case of LoRa, you can
actually build private networks
as well because the cost
of the infrastructure
and the simplicity of the
protocol allow you to do that.
So if you've got a
specific area to cover,
and you want to do that and you
can afford the infrastructure,
you can go out and do that and
still be LoRa WAN compliant
and build your
network with that.
So there's multiple options
in terms of deployment
strategies-- it can be
private, it can be public,
it can be a hybrid mix of both.
So I talked about
the LoRa Alliance.
I mentioned that it's the
industrial lines that's
defining the LoRa WAN standard.
It's an openly
available specification,
so you can access it from
the LoRa Alliance website.
It's a large ecosystem, from
Silicon providers like Semtech,
to solutions, and
everything in between.
It's got a global
certification program
to ensure a certain minimum
level of quality of sensors,
and it defines
end-to-end security.
So one thing to
point out here is
LoRa WAN is really
focused on the Mac, right?
The physical layer--
the radio itself--
is LoRa, and that's a
modulation-- a spread spectrum
modulation.
The MAC Layer is where
you have multiple options.
So you've got three
different classes
in LoRa WAN, which trade
latency for power consumption.
So, in class A, if you have a
sensor that will send data only
when it needs to, and there's
no network initiated traffic,
then that's your
Class A mode, which
is optimized for the lowest,
lowest power consumption.
But the latency's higher because
your network can actually
initiate a communication
with the sensor.
Then you've got
Class B, which is
similar to a beaconing system,
where the network sends out
periodic beacons.
And the sensors listen
to that and they wake up
at those intervals kind of
similar to Wi-Fi beacons
if you want to think about
it that way, which, you know,
has maybe a little bit higher
power consumption than class
A mode, but still is a good
balance between latency
and power consumption.
And then you've got Class
C, where the sensors are
constantly receiving, right?
This could be an application,
like a street light.
We've got a lot of
land deployments
that are going into street
lights in smart cities,
and the street lights
always have line power,
so power consumption
is not a huge concern
for these streetlights.
So they're always receiving.
The other way Class
C is used is if you
want to do firmware updates
over the air, right?
We all know that LoRa WAN is
a low bandwidth, low data rate
system.
So updating firmware
could take a few minutes,
maybe half an hour, depending on
how much data you want to send.
So one of the ways
it's implemented
is you could actually switch
your sensor to Class C mode,
get your updates done quickly,
and then switch it back
to Class A, right?
So there's different ways
of implementing it and still
optimizing for
power consumption.
So if you want
additional information,
Semtech hosts something
called a LoRa community.
It's a website where we
list products, services,
from ecosystem partners.
You can collaborate
with others that
have adopted LoRa technology.
There's about 50
million sensors today
that are actually deployed, so
the technology itself, I think,
is quite proven.
You can get support from
our technical experts
in the community, and get
a lot of good resources
in terms of application
notes and use cases.
And, finally, the
LoRa WAN Academy--
so one interesting
thing we started seeing
was a lot of
university professors
were interested in IoT courses
and experimenting with IoT
and teaching the next
generation of engineers.
So together with partners, we've
created a LoRa WAN Academy,
which essentially gives
universities a LoRa
gateway and a few sensors.
And it's got a full
curriculum that's all online.
So it's provided as courses
in different universities.
We've got about 10 universities
signed up right now.
And it's a full
package that professors
can use to teach courses,
they can use it for research
into the LPWAN space,
and prepare, really,
everybody for real
world IoT, right?
So for additional information
on that, you know,
you can check out the
LoRa WAN Academy website.
With that said, I'm going
to hand it back to Calum.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
CALUM BARNES: Thanks, Vivek.
Before I let Victor
come up here and talk
about network operators
and some real use cases,
I just wanted to
talk a little bit
about how Google Cloud has
recently joined the LoRa
Alliance and what this means
for IoT and from Google's
perspective.
I think it's a
clear signal that we
think standards
and open alliances
will play a huge role on
adoption of IoT and IoT
connectivity.
And LoRa Alliance's goals
around interoperability and open
standards, I think, really align
with Google Cloud's mission
of trying to build the most
open Cloud that there is.
A lot of what we're going
to do with Google Cloud
is we think that the
infrastructure that we have
in the global network that
Google has built, and is
available to our customers
through Google Cloud,
will be great for
network operators.
These are going to be everything
from independent companies
to telecom companies that will
deploy LoRa based stations
and offer LoRa
networks to end users.
And, secondly, we
think it will be
great for the customers
for the use cases
that I talked about before
because we are going
to work with these
network operators
to build integrations from
their networks into Google Cloud
so that companies that are using
LoRa as a connectivity base
layer for their applications
will be able to leverage
the data analytics, machine
learning, and other tools
available to them
inside Google Cloud.
And to tell you
a little bit more
about companies that
are doing that for real,
I'm going to have Victor
from Objenious come up
and tell you more.
VICTOR HAMON: Thank you, Calum.
OK.
So I'm glad to be
with you and to share
what is Objenious-- what we
do as a network operator.
On illustrating, we
have specific use case
about asset tracking.
So Objenious is a subsidiary
of Bouygues Telecom, which
part of Bouygues Group, which
is a huge worldwide corporation
present in value sector,
like telecommunication,
construction, and TV.
Objenious is dedicated
to internet of things.
And, as a company,
we've been into business
on the French market
for almost two years.
Some would say that we are the
visible part of the iceberg
because we act like
a startup and we have
a powerful group behind us.
Objenious has deployed a
national LoRa WAN network
thanks to the help
of Bouygues Telecom.
And we are the first
national network dedicated
to internet of things in France,
thanks to [INAUDIBLE] gateway
all of our friends.
Like that, we cover more
than 95% of the population
and 86% of the territory.
The last point is the
fact that the network
is integrally supervised
and maintained
by the Bouygue
Telecom teams, which
also under other
networks, such as 4G.
To understand what we do, we are
divided the IoT in five layers.
The first concern-- devices,
which we don't manufacture.
In fact, we rely on very
rich ecosystem from the LoRa
Alliance of device
maker and solution maker
to reference them and makes them
available for our customers.
The second one is
network and security.
As a network provider,
we offer services
with some guarantee
for customers,
in particular, in
term of security,
because it can be a
major issue for them.
When the sensor's
connected to our network,
they will be able
to send messages.
And it can be exploited
in SPOT our product,
and I will explain
in the next slide.
And we have a range of
feature from device management
to data visualization.
So it will correspond to the
third and the fourth layer.
And, finally, the last here--
business intelligence,
which will
correspond to end-to-end
solution on specific vertical.
And we are not
addressing that directly.
In fact, we have
a partner, who is
specialized and expert on it,
who will give this last break.
Here-- a screenshot
from a platform, SPOT.
It's a transverse [INAUDIBLE]
global IoT platform, which
are with API and connector.
This platform is
entirely customizable
and truly adds up to the need of
our customer with the features
they desire.
We can separate the
feature in two parts.
The first one is a set of tools
to manage a fleet of objects
in complete autonomy, from the
connection to the management
of all kinds of
objects, including
the technical supervision.
It's a device management.
It's a group on user modeling,
and also the monitoring
of the connectivity.
It's also possible to analyze,
visualize, and supervise
your activity thanks to a
complex use of visualization
and data analysis tool.
Like that, we can
create some dashboard.
And we have some option--
we've added coding, alerting,
and geotracking that we'll show
you in the use case just after.
Here-- a quick overview
of the architecture
of the SPOT system.
So on the left, we have
the LoRa network server
that will manage the
flow between the object
and the network.
It reconfigures a bitrate on,
also, the transmission power.
Globally, LNS will
manage all that's
related to the implementation
of the lower one particle.
All LNS is hosted in
Bouygue Telecom data center.
Then we have a
solution built on GCP.
In order to process a
message from the RNS,
there is a front-end
develop in PSP and React,
and the back end
mainly developed in Go.
The architecture
of the back end is
based on different microservices
from SH processing.
Once the services
images are built,
they are stored in the
Google Cloud registry,
then they are
deployed in containers
orchestrated by Kubernetes.
So that can be used in
three different ways
by the customer directory
on the SPOT platform,
or with rest API, there
with IoT connector.
Why Objenious built
our solution on GCP--
there is five different reasons.
The first one is for
maximum years of use
and day-to-day operation for
our team-- for our IT team.
The next point is to--
and we start during
the keynotes-- it's GKE
and enable to avoid the locking.
It's very important for
Objenious to have that.
The next one is to
use managed services,
and also as a a services
caliber in function of our need,
and the device
[INAUDIBLE] our network.
Sorry.
Customer compatibility-- we
were previously under the Cloud.
And a big customer in France--
Carrefour, that we
work with them--
wanted that we change the
Cloud because they are not
a big fan of the previous Cloud.
And the last one is--
the last one, it's the fact
that, with GCP, we have
the best community services.
So you know everything
about LoRa and Objenious,
so you are expert
in the technology.
So we will go into another
part of the talk about asset
tracking.
And before I talk to you about
a specific use case of mobility,
I will show you a short
video on another client case
to get a quick overview
of the value chain
and the different issues that
might exist on this topic.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's infringement.
There is subtitle.
NARRATOR: For the
greater Paris project,
200 kilometers of tunnels
will be done by 2030.
This will generate 43 million
tons of excavated materials
that will need removing.
To control its environmental
impact and traceability,
the [FRENCH] invented a
platform for its contractors.
Since June 2016,
Bouygues [FRENCH]
has been working on a
complementary system
to make inputting
on the interface
easier and guaranteeing
traceability thanks to the geo
localization of its trucks
THOMAS COLOBY: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
ANTOINE SURMONT:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
NARRATOR: With the tablet,
it's possible to specify
the type of materials the
site where it's unloaded
and its content.
The truck can then hit the road.
ANTOINE SURMONT:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
NARRATOR: With LoRa, the French
network for connected objects,
Bouygue Telecom passes
on all this information.
The control panel then
tells you where and when
unloading took place.
ANTOINE SURMONT:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
NARRATOR: For site
managers, the solution
has numerous advantages.
ARNAUD JURAS: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
NARRATOR: Expected on
sites in June 2017,
Ubysol could become
the most reliable way
to meet the needs
of the [FRENCH]..
VICTOR HAMON: So let's
talk about tracking on IoT
with Objenious.
First, an interesting number
that we have seen among all IoT
projects in Objenious--
more than 75% of projects
have geolocation needs.
Obviously, they
are not identical.
It can be tracking on
equipment with great accuracy
with intensive
sending of messages
because the object
is in movement
and the customer wants to know
the position every 10 minutes.
Or it can be just an
approximate position
to know if my object
is still in the area
because my object is
supposed to be static.
This number is directly
linked to the advantage
of LoRa and the fact
that the battery can
be very long so
message can be sent
on the great range, the
low cost, and the fact
that it's a flexible approach.
The LoRa technology can be
applied to almost every sector.
So lets go in detail for
our customer problem.
So the customer case
that I will detail
you concerning one of the
European automotive leader.
This project concerns essential
equipment for the supply chain
in order to chip the
manufactured product.
It's called packaging.
To give a bit of
context, the company
has designed a
factory in Europe.
In England, in France,
or either in Spain,
it's working together
on different components
of the car.
The packaging-- there
is a lot of packaging
and a large number
of packaging using.
Its represent millions
of units and thousands
of different type.
And this equipment is
used between the plant,
but also with the supplier.
So it's a problem
because packaging
is very important
for the business
to have a good efficient
flow of pack of goods,
as well as a supply chain.
So without that, it leads
to disruption and money
waste because of
extra cost linked
to the problem of supply chain.
So as I say, as I previously
said, there is a lot of assets.
It represents a huge amount.
But a single equipment
does not justify
[INAUDIBLE] to track them.
So that's why
they're using LoRa.
And the aim of this project
was to track packaging in order
to improve the efficiency of the
management of this equipment.
To answer to the
customer problem,
I think we have identified
three main components.
The coverage-- how Objenius
[INAUDIBLE] LoRa WAN converged
with sides of French territory.
So location-- thanks to
LoRa, we have different types
of location with different
level of accuracy
and different properties.
And, finally, visualization.
I was a customer going
to see the doctor.
I was going to be able to
exploit it and waltz a business
indicator where you need it.
So let's go in detail
of each of them.
So regarding the coverage of
different sites inside France,
there is two options available.
The first concern-- roaming
with other European player.
Since LoRa is present
globally, some foreign operator
have also deployed our LoRa
WAN network in that country.
We have already signed some
agreements, roaming agreements,
with some other player, like,
such as Switzerland, Belgium,
Germany, but many others.
And so, roaming is
very interesting
because it's made possible
to respond and answer
to this kind of problematic
at a European level or even
worldwide level.
The counterpart of
roaming is the fact
that we depend on so little
of the payment of his partner.
The second option is
coverage on demand.
It's the name of
Objenious software.
Basically, just to start a
getaway in the planned customer
sites.
The gateway is already
connected to a LNS.
So the message is directory
linked, sends to our RNS.
It's quick and easy to install.
The problem with
these solution is
that we have the
location of our assets
and they are on the site where
the gateway is installed.
As previously said, that there
is different type of location--
with LoRa, there are several
ways to locate your equipment.
It will be unadvantageous.
Among the four possibilities,
we will observe different level
of accuracy from few
meters to hundreds
of meters, different battery
consumption, or different
using outdoor or indoor.
The choice of the clients
can be a combination
of several of them.
With this wide choice,
we are able to respond
to different scenarios and
provide the [INAUDIBLE] suite
to customer use case.
One of them is
very interesting--
is TDOA, the second one.
TDOA-- so time
difference of arrival--
and its based on the
triangulation of messages
with at least three gateways.
The TDOA is really interesting
because without GPS,
its not precise accuracy.
And in [INAUDIBLE] area, we
have a long battery life,
so this solution has the
best cost accuracy ratio.
And, finally, the last point--
how the customer
will see the data.
So it's also a platform SPOT,
which is possible to visualize.
and have a dedicated
feature to geotracking.
So on the screen, there
is a map that we can check
the position of every asset.
We've color coded to
give us information
about the status
of the equipment--
if there is a problem,
a technical area,
or some stuff like that.
It's also possible to visualize
the path of the device
on different time interval.
We also can configure
area of interest in order
to monitoring specific
graphical area,
the alert is there is a device
enter who'd go out this area.
And, finally, the last
point with this feature
is the fact that all the
position are recurred,
and it's available to user
to have a value statement.
In the case of the
European automotive leader,
they are using the SPOT
platform at the beginning
to have a very important
business metrics that
build a personal dashboard
based on this information
and based on our API.
And just quickly to
sum up the benefit
of this solution for the
customer-- so with SPOT
on LoRa, it could locate
any single equipment
at any location so data
were available to share
with any system that we
can build is on dashboard,
and create its KPI.
And the last point--
there is an interesting
payback of roughly one year.
So to conclude, LoRa
and the project in IoT.
It's working, and it's
already in production.
[MUSIC PLAYING]